A bird house that looks like a
surveillance camera
and Mister Spock-topus.
It's episode 26
of LÜT.
Now, here's a perfume designed to make you smell
like a book. And Generate offers a limited edition
life wall clock.
It's just like a normal clock,
except slowed down by a factor of 61,320.
Every number represents a year
and it's meant to go around once in
the average person's life.
Keep your head warm by making your own
knitted brain hat,
but if you prefer ears, put some ears
on your ears, or around your neck,
or on your finger, or how about a mouth?
In fact, just get a nose ring.
No, no, no.
A nose ring.
Fifty Shades of Grey
Learn them. Seriously.
Here's a poster delineating
fifty shades of grey.
And these plates are perfect for
finger food, because they are finger sized.
Now, if you're going to be making
sandwiches, use this crust cutter to turn
it into two
dolphins and a heart.
If it's too early for sandwiches,
simply be a cereal killer.
Tuxedo
ring, emoticon rings,  inflatable Cthulhu arm or
or this touching little number.
Two rings
that come attached at the middle.
You snap them apart, so that you and one
other person
have perfectly matching, unique two-of-a-kind rings.
Time moves under
this watch's face, crossing the red present line.
Now, you can't see the future and the past is gone,
faded away.
For lunch, carry your sandwiches
in disguise bags. And rock in a rocking
chair designed to generate electricity
while you rock ... paper, scissors
necklaces are cool and sausage neck
pillows are even better.
When you fall asleep, don't do it alone, with these sheets
which have a fake little dog on them to
keep you company. The goofy eyes on this
clock tell you the time.
The one on your left looks to be hour
and the other looks at the minute.
This gumball tastes like apple cobbler,
but it's just the desert in your TV dinner gumset.
These two are flavored like roast beef
and buttered corn.
And these envelopes are fruit-flavoured,
when you lick them to stick them.
Oh look, a bathroom mist designed to smell
like a baby's head. Here's a special
thermally insulated bag that's great for
transporting
wine, but it looks like a cheap paper bag.
And you can frighten people
when you sip from your cracked
mug, full of death wish coffee.
A special roast guaranteed to be the strongest
coffee you've ever tasted.
Both in terms of flavor
and caffeine content.
Your iPhone can snap into this little
guy to become your pet
and these urine sample bottles contain a delicious
yellow liquid candy. Quiet down the
baby with a pacifiers that puts a
mustache
under his nose. This straw building kit
allows you to make your own custom
straws for mixing and sharing drinks
and these straws give you a kissy face.
Of course, make sure you're fancy
and use these fine disposable paper cups.
Or use an R2-D2 mug or glasses
designed to express each one of the seven
deadly sins.
For instance, pride,
sloth,
gluttony, wrath.
Here's a company that will take two
photos of your head and use them to print
a 3D action figure head of your face.
The smallest size can be used on LEGO dudes.
Or look, just use this backpack that
turns into a basketball
hoop.
Or this goopy mud that changes color with your mood
and why roll your sushi when you could
pack up this device
and a have a sushi bazooka?
Here's a fun free thing.
Desktop Gremlins offers easy to build
templates for fun paper
creations - video game characters, books, movies.
He even made a special YouTube Space Lab
papercraft, because on September 13th
the winning experiments will be done in outer space
live, right here on YouTube.
Ok, finally,
let's get beard-y.
A beard for your Apple,
lavender beard conditioner, beard love buttons
and last, but not least, a beer/beard
cozy. Amazing, right?
Well, for more cool things you can actually own
I highly suggest watching Naomi Kyle's show Cheap
Cool Crazy. It's on IGN's channel START,
which is full of original programming
for nerds like us.
Oh and, and,
as always,
thanks for watching.